and so when it comes to wearables for me
you know the wristwatch i mean we the
wristwatch dates back to the 1600s right
it's in many ways the original personal
computing form factor
[Music]
thank you for being on 20 minute leaders
how are you good good it's my pleasure
i am so excited to speak to you about
your journey you know you your linkedin
says
two-time googler not many people have
that on have that a lot of people have
ex google or google or but two-time
googler that's i think something special
that i want to hear about i want to hear
about your experience with you know the
the watch industry and the smartware
how how are we advancing you know with
it with different devices that are
you know in our lives but with
technology and you know your journey
from
corporate to startup to another startup
to corporate leor take me through a
journey how do you get started with what
do you do
uh yeah so i mean you know google when i
first joined google in 2003
it wasn't quite that corporate yet there
were a couple thousand people in the
company
um and it was still still felt and i
think in retrospect obviously was
early days wow 2003 that's wow
yeah yeah um you know and the story i
tell since
you know since we're israeli is is um
the i was the first israeli at google
who was not
either software engineer like working in
hr you know
and um so israel was the best the ads
business in israel was kind of my 20
project which wow quickly grew and then
i basically just to give you a sense of
how we did things back then
i recruited my friends who were in
university to help
translate um text strings as we were
localizing
uh the the adwords product into
unbelievable
you know hebrew and local currency um
and then was as as
the the business kept growing uh
you know i i wasn't [__] it up um
and that's always a good thing yes yes
um and and so we and and i lobbied for a
while and
that google should sort of get more
serious about israel to open an office
and so when we finally decided to to do
that i was
i was kind of first person on the ground
to
hire and train the team and kind of help
them get set up and integrate with
uh integrate with google broadly
and then from there i did a similar role
kind of
uh building and managing a larger
cluster
what are some of the challenges that go
with what are some of the challenges
that go with you know bringing a
business like
like ads like google adwords to another
country
you know both you know obviously the
localization of it but also in terms of
mindset
you know looking at a whole different
country whole different
like operations what comes with what
entails with with that
endeavor you know i think it's like with
any it's almost like uh
it's almost like moving countries right
uh so this so it's a big logistical
challenge that contain
contains within it um lots and lots of
smaller problems
right so what you do is you try to kind
of break down
here's all the problems and and almost
turn it into
like a step-by-step kind of okay so
first
you need to establish a local tax entity
local legal
entity so that you can operate in the
smart gate right then if you're getting
paid again this is before
stripe and you know with the every every
you know accepting foreign currency you
had to
have uh largely homegrown solutions for
that
so you have to figure out how to get
paid um how to
establish your taxation status you know
it's just basically a list of problems
that you cross off right
who who's gonna who's gonna run the the
this entity
what kind of rules do we need uh what
does
our business objective look like you
know in the end
uh we had something like a 150 page
presentation
that was kind of the roadmap right like
the business plan for
for google in this new country
unbelievable okay wait but but then leo
you know there's so much that i want to
cover so you move on to you know head of
the business development
at at ifttt now i've used ifttt myself
to help me automate some processes and
for whoever doesn't know
ifttt if this than that it's this idea
that we can create our own
paths to productivity and and you have
automated different processes
integrating different applications right
and yeah no that's exactly right and so
then what does that mean you know
leading the business development after
10 years at google you decide to go
and you know between what he just told
me and when you left for ifttt you've
done so much obviously
and you run business development also
within google for different
jurisdictions
so but then he transitioned to the
startup life and what was that
transition like
uh you know it was so i left google
after 10 years
and joined uh if and when i joined that
there are nine people
on on staff so it was still very small
it was it was you know the product was
well established and still doing well
and i love it
but at the time the company was still
small
and you know there were things by the
time i
left google it was much bigger you know
what
i i would say that it does meet the
definitely your definition of corporate
here right so it was
definitely leaving the big company life
behind um
it was a little bit like jumping off the
ledge right especially having spent
professionally i grew up at google right
uh
and what i will say is overall the
experience was
there were i didn't find that i was at
much of a disadvantage or that i even
missed some of the big company
creature comforts and perks as much as i
feared i might
you know at the end of the day at the
end of the day
what you have in the snack room or you
know where you get your lunch is
you know those those things can have a
cumulative effect
to kind of optimize your working day but
it's not like not having these things as
catastrophic and i also found that
you know it was professionally and
creatively extremely liberating
to um come into a much smaller
environment and basically
have to tackle problems end to end and
spend time thinking about how do we
impact things for our users how do we
impact things for the ecosystem
right rather than how do i navigate the
internal
you know checks and balances and all the
kinds of points of friction
that a big company has on the way to
getting something done
right and then you know running business
development for
a small like fast growing product very
very you know focused
rather than you know dealing within the
the business organization of google
how does that how does that fare what
are the different priorities that you
have to keep in mind
uh you know so i think uh you you kind
of you kind of need to dial up the
hustle factor quite a bit
because it's you know at a startup it
really is much more
existentially critical they get things
done i think it's also
hard even even for you know if you have
a hot brand
um it can still be difficult to get mind
share
uh and what's most diff from from big
companies that you're trying to partner
with
um and what's most difficult is getting
uh prospective partners or customers to
trust you
right to trust that the company will you
know that there's longevity
right uh and that that you're you're
kind of a
good investment of their money or time
uh
so those are those are some of the
bigger challenges i think on the plus
side
you are startups can can
can take bigger risks they there's less
kind of baggage there's less legacy
stuff to deal with
so even as something as simple as uh
look i'm making a call a call out to
nike to
suss them out about something you don't
have to
you just need to to find a contact and
set up time with them
you don't need to worry about like well
are there other conversations going on
with nike
or like is this team working with them
right which by the time i left google
what was was the case right like there
were lots and lots of courses
the breadth of activity was so was so
vast of course
uh so you can you need you need to
hustle more but you can be
more there's less dissipation of effort
if that makes sense and i think that's
true
i found that to be the case as a startup
ceo as well is
you know you're kind of um you don't
have
uh the advantages of a big platform to
go with
but you also once you focus on doing
something
99 of your effort is just doing it
instead of
you know doing it and being kind of
doing your diligence or like
kind of satisfying checks and balances
and kinds of things that
again a larger public company um
has has a responsibility to go through
so you
you move from corporate to joining the
leadership of an existing company and
then you decide to go full throttle on
the entrepreneurship path
and and just create a startup yourself
you end up selling that startup to
google which is actually how you go back
to google and that is the the two timer
but but walk me through you know you
become passionate about
something that i don't believe you've
dealt with before right this whole the
sonic
smartware and how we're interacting with
technology on our bodies
yeah yeah so i i um
you know in my previous my first run i
guess at google
i worked on a lot of emerging uh
hardware form factors and
you know was was involved with with some
mobile technologies early on i did a lot
of work on speech recognition
uh for instance and location uh
and so when
when i started chronologics really was
we started the company
in late 2014 um you know i've been
thinking about it for a while
but i also um saw that apple launched
the apple watch then and i i you know i
became convinced that sort of this is
where the puck was headed right
okay um that was wearables were going to
be
a significant personal computing form
factor
and this was this was a problem that i
wanted to take part in solving
uh so so that's kind of how how we came
to work on the space i also think you
know since you know if
um and by virtue of if being a connector
between different products and services
uh early on
i i also got to spend a lot of time with
wearable companies and
kind of creating these integrations that
allowed people to for instance flash
flash my light disco theme if i meet my
fitbit step count right those kinds of
things
uh so there so i saw that there was a
lot of interest and a lot of value
for users not necessarily in that silly
example but in
not silly at all i have to smart
wearables 100 and then
but but you know you go then to the more
software side you actually build an
operating system right for
for wearables and so you're coming in
from the you know like this business
background and the head of business
development
and you go down and you're saying okay
well i'm gonna actually go and and do
like heavy software eventually to be
integrated onto these wearables
is that is that a you know a the agent
the traditional path for somebody coming
from business development to then create
a
you know software-based startup uh you
know i'm more familiar so
so it's it's been done i'm much more
familiar with people starting out
for instance getting computer science
degrees or starting out right in
technical roles and making kind of
joining the dark side of going into
business roles uh
i think that i think that sort of
you know i'm a little adverse to kind of
labels and labeling people in their
careers and
i see that a lot even as i you know
interview people or as a hiring manager
at different times
you know we have a tendency of thinking
of someone based on the job the
the last job that they've done or you
know the the role they've done the most
of and i think we
run the risk of kind of shortchanging
ourselves by saying oh i'm a
i'm a business guy i can't like spec out
uh a product or build a prototype of a
ui
you know uh for for a smartwatch for
instance
and like you know my point is you never
know until you try
totally right so but look i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna bs you i think there are
you know there's limited efficiency
right there's diminishing returns
there's
there is a lot there's a strong argument
to be made for like
kind of doubling down in one role of
course um
and i and i certainly you know
have proportionately over developed
you know business negotiation strategy
muscles relative to
some of the other things that i needed
to use that's no no that's really
that's really awesome okay now i want
you to talk to me about this thing so
right now we have so many people
around you know walking around with
these things on their wrists you've been
in this space for now six years
and you know you've been thinking about
this daily and you know
it's one of the key one of the questions
that you know always came up between me
and my friends
as we're seeing this you know world
unfold and as we're getting introduced
to this new phenomena of like our phone
on our hand
where where is the world going i mean
are i mean how do you see
smartware technology integrated into
society and
how you know i want to play like a mind
game of where you're going to see this
going the next 10 years
and what things we can be excited about
or or pessimistic about
yeah i mean for me it's it's it's really
it's really a source of excitement
um look i think i'm a big believer in
the notion that
computing is becoming ubiquitous right
so everything is going to everything
around us is becoming connected
um it doesn't necessarily mean that
everything's gonna have a screen or a
microphone
or you know but but things are gonna
have sensing capabilities inputs and
outputs
uh and and ultimately you know the world
they're only is going to be
a set of devices that kind of talk to
each other um and there will hopefully
be
and i think you know i certainly see
google
as being one of the services that can
help bring
all of these disparate uh endpoints
together to
unlock value for for the user right so
right most reviews
uh so i think that's true in general i
think with
um and so we're kind of moving from a
world in which
you you know used to sit at a computer
and then you kind of took your laptop
with you
and now you've got a computer with you
all the time in your pocket um
moving to this modality where like the
computer is kind of just ambiently
um around right um
and so the when it comes to wearables
for me
you know the wristwatch i mean we the
wristwatch dates back to the 1600s right
it's in many ways the original personal
computing form factor
and so it's tried and true and there's a
lot of value in having something on your
wrist both as like a quick
kind of glanceable uh device for
interactions for consuming information
and increasingly and i think we're
seeing this industry-wide with smart
watches
as a place to to fit sensors
that can help you understand what's
going on in your body totally
and potentially even save your life um
so i think the the the and this is not
i'm not saying that the watch is going
to like eat the phone i don't i don't
think that's happening but in a broad
constellation of computing devices that
you that you work with
um the wristwatch has these three
critical advantages to me one is
it works and yeah comfortable with it
two good place for sensors
three good form factor for for certain
interactions and consuming information
what's missing
so what's missing from my interaction
with my watch right now that you think
i will be i will have in the coming
years
uh so i think what's missing there's
still friction
right there we haven't eliminated so i
think specifically things like battery
life you know battery yeah these devices
still quite limited
um it's another thing to charge like
there's some clunkiness to that
um it we're still largely i mean i think
there are kind of cellular connected
options for wearables but i think
that's still a little bit the exception
you know it's expensive it's again
their power implications there by the
way that friction that you should that
you mentioned before
does do you see when you know i'm
looking at the general consumer
when they purchase a watch do they use
it as frequently as they would of a
regular watch
or does it get to a point where you know
they put it away they forget about it
they they stop using it they come back
to it what's the relationship to of
today's consumers
with wearables yeah i mean look i think
attrition as with any product is key and
and definitely the battery life there's
a lot of data that shows that like
you know once you have to take something
off every so often to charge it but
dramatically
you know that can significantly increase
the chances that you're going to forget
to put it back on
right you know which intuitively makes
sense right um
so so so that's that's definitely a
challenge that exists
um but you know in general obviously
people do
many people are very very happy with
with their smart watches and and use
them on an ongoing basis
um and there's also a link of um
the fitness and wellness aspect of these
devices because it's
again that's you can't get that from
your phone right
right certainly not uh all of it and not
as easily
uh and so so i think that that that kind
of uh plays into it
i think there are other challenges with
the smartwatches i think things
new technologies we're we kind of we all
had this sugar high
from the smartphone revolution which was
a very rapid onset
transformation right and then we look at
things like ai
we look at things like um uh
augmented reality uh you know drones
right
like these are these are technology
technological development cycles that
are
are taking a little bit longer to bear
fruit um it doesn't mean they're not
going to be monumental
uh it just means that we need to be
patient and i think the same is true
with wearables and with the smartwatch
in particular i think we're still in
this modality of kind of like developing
these devices like
phone and as we move away from that
we're gonna see
greater adoption and ultimately more
value very very cool
i have to ask you know you left google
for a few years and i'm extrapolating to
any core any company that grows
you know naturally with time you come
back a few years later
you come back to the same company but it
has to be a different company in some
sense
were you surprised by any you know
social norms or you know different
things that all of a sudden you're like
like wow like i did not expect to see
this when i came back
uh yeah i mean things again we it's
it's hard to grok the different
timelines right so like an organization
evolves at a different
pace then then you know you experience
your own career
um it was mostly the same i think that
there were
some um positive surprises i think in
general
kind of the the debate style and the
the the team dynamics have have shifted
and have been shifting towards
you know being not that i was ever like
a a huge problem in my in my first run
but more inclusive
um more just nicer more more actively
respectful
well i think google is an exemplary i
mean google i think
you know worldwide is known as one of
the companies that are you know
advocating like very openly advocating
for
you know healthier debate and more
supportive ecosystem and more inclusion
so that's
that comes at no surprise but but i'm
sure that it has to be an interesting
experience leaving a company at x going
through y and z
and coming back at the w and then all of
a sudden it's like
it's like you're back in the same place
but you've gone through all these
incredible transformations yourself
going through leadership at a startup
creating and selling a startup yourself
and now back and working on this domain
we're almost out of time i can't believe
it but i have to ask you the most
important question
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
uh you know i so thoughtful
uh critical and helpful
thoughtful critical how yeah that's
that's how i would like to describe
myself i love it leor
thank you very very much it's been a
pleasure and and just as a fun fact you
just mentioned before this talk that you
were one of the founders
with my father and amir and they are of
google campus tel aviv which is like
an awesome awesome surprise to hear it's
it's so fantastic
actually we had michal on the show
and mikhail walter levy yeah a few weeks
back and we had amir shavat as our first
episode
and and so i'm i'm slowly building the
the you're crossing the names off your
list
exactly take care thank you very much
bye thank you